enfin bon soir alors la coupe du monde
au brésil commence demain et on a la
chance de recevoir didier deschamps pour
en parler bonjour c'est didier deschamps
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
future championne des moines au brésil
non je plaisante bien sûr bon on a eu
des coups durs vous avez vu que franck
ribéry ne va pas au brésil parce qu'il a
des problèmes de dos qui viennent donc
s'ajouter à ces problèmes de face et de
profil
je plaisante le point positif c'est que
l'on va pouvoir profiter de l'été pour
reprendre ses études
c'est bien même si ça risque de leur
faire bizarre aux autres élèves de ce2
bonne soirée
là aussi il ya aussi franck dubosc qui
connaît bien le brésil salut c'est
franck dubosc à un cheikh en loose et on
jean-claude à le brésil bragi au
magnifique pays j'y suis allé pour
changer de sexe
ouais j'en voulais à moins imposants je
n'en ai rien fait à la place je suis
allé me perdre dans la jungle
amazonienne d'ailleurs public
je devais faire face aux assauts d'une
gigantesque femelle anna combat la
pauvreté tombée amoureuse de jean claude
elle avait pris pour un mâle de son
espèce gourmande to fly
en tout 15 heures le toit jean-claude
comment parler du brésil sans accueillir
bernard de la villardière
bonsoir pendant un mois
tous les regards seront tournés vers le
brésil et sa coupe du monde dans la
prochaine émission
nous enquêterons sur la face cachée de
ce pays continent nous découvrirons
ainsi que le brésil est le premier
producteur mondial d'éthanol
nous parlerons de ce biocarburant tiré
de la canne à sucre
non je déconne on va parler de sexe de
drogue et surtout de [ __ ] à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro d'
enquête
si on sort un peu du fou et on va
prendre des nouvelles de quelqu'un qu'on
aime beaucoup ce elie semoun or vous me
connaissez un petit peu ma situation à
la d or je suis comme une feuille de
papier a4 qui n'auraient jamais vu
l'imprimante est vierge désespérément
vierge
donc c'était blonde à forte poitrine
sais-tu il adhère morini bosc
tant pis quant à toi parce que
et alors là dedans donc on n'a pas de
nouvelles depuis très longtemps c'est
jean claude van damme au hockey bonjour
envoie ses bientôt notre tom plus tard
c'est super on chantait cyril cyril
était comme moi ok tout le monde est
pareil est né le 23 septembre
et moi aussi je suis né aussi tu en es
pareil on est paré et le jeune général
de gaulle aussi c'est pareil mais bon
c'est un peu différent à cause de sa
casquette
j'aime la vie on est super proche toi et
moi parce que si on avait la même mère
et le même frère ou ne le perd on se
déferait rockets n'y a pas de hasard
dans la vie
quand je disais déjà quand j'arrive en
amérique
j'ai cristallisé mes émotions dans ma
force de penser c'est mon pépé ait eu la
fête est là il est loin de voir aller on
accueille un des jurés de danse avec les
stars c'est jean marc généreux
j'adore votre émission
ces cas là je vous kiffe c'est pour ça
que je vous mets comme si j'étais rocco
siffredi je vous mettrais un 30
si j'étais christophe derrière je vous
mettrais 1 500 qu'embrasse christophe
l'important c'est de participer aux jo
j'ai chauffé est extraordinaire et ça
j'aime ça